remote sensing has become increasingly
important for understanding and managing
agriculture this paper reviews existing
literature on remote sensing for mapping
cropping practices grouping them into
three categories crop succession
cropping patterns and cropping
techniques
most studies were exploratory and
focused on local scales relying heavily
on ground data and local knowledge
future research should focus on using
multiple sensors land stratification and
expert knowledge driven methods
Additionally the Sentinel constellation
will provide improved monitoring
capabilities for food security and
better management of agro-environmental
issues
this article was authored by Agnes bake
Damien arver Beatrice Bellen and others